what do they say about me tonight
so hot that snowbirds visit him for the
winter
i'll take that
very very true i'm very hot all right
all right all right happy thursday
everyone what a glorious evening we have
in store because it's time for
gut-felled industrial hygiene
corporation in conjunction with
self-assembling elves presents
how to be a journalist
with your host
brad pitt
[Music]
so let's start with a story you aren't
hearing much about
because it involves a group the media
loves black lives matter one of their
activists quintes brown was charged in
an attempted assassination of jewish
democrat mayoral candidate craig
greenberg in louisville kentucky i know
you're thinking the same thing i did
when i first read it jewish people live
in kentucky
the suspect just like cnn and msnbc was
an advocate for socialist and communist
ideals and often criticized gun-loving
republicans as a columnist for a
louisville paper yes he's a member of
the press well it was either that or
become a college professor
here is the pro gun control shooter on
joy reads show
roll the tape
honestly now it's very hard to feel
safer school but where i come from is i
feel less safe in my community and so
like i love how the emphasis is it's
like this isn't a school safety issue
like this is a school safety issue this
is a gun violence issue because gun
violence does not affect schools but
communities churches clubs everywhere so
at school and it's very hard to feel
safe now because it's like a war zone
what humans need we need common sense
gun reform get rid of his heart rifles
so yeah he's for gun control just yours
not his it makes it easier to shoot
politicians without getting shot
so you think some journalists would
wonder if far left rhetoric and
demonization of whites or jews led to
this violence
someone maybe like joy reid
in america there's a thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
particularly
male white tears
really white tears in general because
that's what carrots are right
they carrying out and then as soon as
you get caught
green water works
[Music]
white men can get away with that too and
it has the same effect
oh it's scary now i'm not gonna say that
since the music bothers me it's like
it's very it makes it into like a horror
movie kind of thing i'm not gonna say
that reads racist words incited violence
against whites but i'm not gonna not say
it
surely it doesn't help when you
constantly target one race for abuse so
how did the las vegas son report this
attempted murder they blamed the right
claiming that violent language from
right-wing politicians like donald trump
was enough motivation
for the shooting quote we've all heard
this with our own ears we have trump
drawing cheers at rallies by suggesting
violence against his opponents gop
lawmakers and candidates trying to whip
their followers into a frenzy with talk
of taking up arms against so-called
forms of tyranny like masked mandates
well i gotta say for a publication
called the sun the people who write for
it aren't that bright
yeah
you're welcome
and they claim that we've heard all of
this with our own ears not us buddy all
we hear is millions of people right now
laughing at you for your idiocy but at
least uh the son didn't blame it on the
shooter's car
meanwhile where's the shooter he's not
in jail the louisville community bail
fund posted the one hundred thousand
dollar bond for him yeah the party of
red flag laws bailed out a deranged man
who just tried to shoot a politician
it's kind of like if sir hans her hand
failed they're giving him another shot
and don't you dare blame kamala the
person she bailed out is accused of
murder in minnesota
which brings up another question why
don't we know whose money bailed him out
why aren't enterprising journalists
using hack data to find out who's
responsible for freeing an attempted
murderer well maybe because they're
hacks themselves but look at what the
press did to the truckers in canada
places like the washington post took
names and numbers from a hacked list of
donations and started calling people who
gave as little as 40 bucks to the convoy
like geraldo's hot tub it's as gross as
it is unsurprising
[Laughter]
i just love that picture and the only
shooting that these so-called terrorists
in canada have done is at the goal
during street hockey the only thing they
threaten is the timeliness of our amazon
packages
no wonder everyone hates the press
including their own parents they
couldn't look into the president's son's
business dealings which they lied about
being hacked but if a coffee shop owner
donates to peaceful civil disobedience
they stick the outrage mob on them then
the government takes away their bank
accounts the doxing has caused more
damage than the protests
in short journalists who despise the
blue-collar class painted a target on
people who supported a non-violent
protest simply because they saw them as
uneducated rubes uneducated rubes mind
you who you and your country rely on to
make it run every day you slime this is
class warfare with an over-educated
self-absorbed class taking out their
aggressions on everyone they deem
beneath them well everyone but an
attempted murderer of a jewish mayoral
candidate that crime doesn't fit the
narrative so let it slide but these are
weird times so weird that i find myself
agreeing for once with ilhan omar
who defended those who were doxxed and
later harassed by reporters after
donating to the freedom convoy
be careful ilhan your patriotism is
starting to show after the washington
post began hunting down the doc's people
omar said this quote
i failed to see why any journalist felt
the need to report on a shop owner
making such an insignificant donation
rather than to just get them harassed
it's unconscionable and journalists need
to do better well amen's sister as her
husband slash brother would say
it's not often i find myself in staunch
agreement with a radical communist but
that's what the journalist class does to
you it unites all of us against them
it's gotten so bad i'm going bowling
with the squad this saturday
us night tonight's guest she's got the
longest resume and the shortest name fox
business correspondent susan lee
he'll lead men into battle and then take
them clubbing out
afterwards host of rob smith is
problematic rob smith
oh you got a big yay there
she's like a dart board sharp and pointy
and hanging around at bars fox news
contributor cat tim
and we'll always see eye to eye as long
as i'm on a fire escape
my massive sidekick and the nwa world
television champion
tyrus
susan always a pleasure to see you
i want to ask you about the business
element of this this is really creepy
that like you can like there's people
that give forty dollars to like some
donate like donation to a something they
see on tv and all of a sudden reporters
are calling them right that's really
really being docs
yeah well i'll say the good thing about
the the trucker protest is that in
canada you know we play street hockey
and so at least with all the truckers on
the street that means no cars come
through so you have continuous games of
street hockey in canada
that is the silver lining that is the
silver alignment in all of this but just
to get back to the
blm that's shooting in louisville i was
just looking so i did some research
victim you know i mean craig greenberg i
i prefer to talk about the victim and
give him
more coverage than say the actual
perpetrator but have you looked at his
platform for mayor no
very democratic yes he's very left-wing
so he wants a lower tuition green
spending racial justice and he still
gets shot yeah he didn't get he got shot
at okay this is the difference between
murder
quickly i think that was the he was
lucky yeah the difference between
attempted murder and murder is that the
guy the suspect has to be bad at it
right now
that is what blows my mind it's like
just make sure you get a lower sentence
because you're an incompetent killer he
i mean like that's what i'm saying it's
like it's like an assassin gets a second
chance if he's bad but it also looks bad
when blm puts up a hundred thousand
dollars bail don't you think i mean
wouldn't that money be spent better on
other things
like on me for example anything would be
better justice how about that yes well
me too okay hashtag
well look it seems that the um and i'm
really glad that the uh shooter was such
a bad shot but i mean he was doing all
this stuff about gun control he
obviously wasn't taking shooting classes
right true because he's obviously a bad
shot but what i love about uh of being a
democrat it really does mean that you
never have to say you're sorry or own up
to anything and if something does happen
then it's a republican's fault right it
reminds me of that meme where it's like
democrat like leftist shoots democrat
and then they look at that look at the
camera they're like why did you do this
donald trump yes so it's kind of like
one of those things it's just there's no
responsibility anymore yeah they
actually had i think what happened was
wrote the editorial
before before anything happened and it
fit their assumptions so they and then
then all of a sudden they go oh wow and
then they tried they actually changed
their editorial and pretending they're
hoping they go like wow it's been they
said at the bottom it's been updated no
you actually changed the entire focus
because you were found out by some you
know some people that actually read it
but that's how fake news works because
if somebody was reading this op-ed and
they didn't know the facts of the case
they would think that it was some crazy
right-winger that went crazy right but
how do you think the shooter would feel
reading that op-ed oh he'd be really
pissed yeah exactly like the culmination
of his life's work of hating republicans
and then there's this whole editorial
said he did it for donald trump yeah no
because he loves trump so much it's like
they it's like
their cultural appropriation they're
like oh it's like how dare you blame it
on right wingers that's my gig it's kind
of like when they call larry elder a
white supremacist it's like the white
supremacists are like no no no the whole
point the whole point is we don't let
blacks into our group how dare you how
dare you tyrus on their moniker
exactly exactly what do you make of this
whole story you know um greg your
monologues are always
on point but i i have to disagree with
you he always does this he butters me up
i've learned i've learned through waving
through the waters of fox news that a
compliment
before goes a long way because
especially with your little ego if i
butter you up you get caught up and
you're greg like yes that's true i am
brilliant and i can throw the insult in
and it won't get edited out so you have
to be on the payroll to talk to greg
like that yeah it's true and it's true
you just give him a compliment first you
do the compliment sandwich compliment
yeah
and then another got filled yeah you can
pretty much get anything out of it
something that people talk about when
i'm not around just us we do again again
we talk about every week
because you you
give them too much credit there it
wasn't a mistake they didn't jump the
gun no the whole point of it is about no
accountability right the young brother
who they gave talking points to and even
when he gave that speech he was speaking
he kept repeating himself
because they take young minds like that
and he's responsible for his actions but
they feed him the hate and they convince
him that they if i've been there when i
was coming up it was all the malcolm x
stuff until you actually researched what
the issues were
and he hears that and he hears that but
they never bothered to think about his
character everybody praised him because
he said what he was told to say
but you build these young minds full of
hate
and then when they unleash you're not
going to take responsibility you're not
going to say hey we didn't see the signs
they say yeah it's it's the right it's
their fault it's not our fault it's the
system and it's it's about they just
don't believe in accountability and it
fits the narrative and i bet tyrus when
you were coming up and you were getting
all of that stuff like it probably made
you extra mad because you guys are
always the angriest yes like y'all are
always just like yeah we're like you
know we
they did this to malcolm x and just that
and then one day it was reading was like
wait we killed him
wait a minute oh no wait no where's the
clint and then also again
i just want to make one more point this
is a little bit serious like a lot a lot
of people really don't talk about there
is a strain of hardcore anti-semitism
among the black far left that comes out
over and over and over again um and this
is i think an example of that like i
think that the fact that this politician
was jewish is not um something that
was not relevant
you see that in the relationship to how
the the hard left looks at israel and
absolutely
it kind of comes out of there a lot look
at what happened to karen johnson i mean
whoopi goldberg a couple weeks ago right
so like it all comes out hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else